and we mainly proud of my students we
lack facilities that many schools take
for granted as a teacher I just want to
have a positive impact not only in my
country within the whole of Africa
[Music]
[Music]
teaching is in my blood my father was a
teacher my uncles and cousins also
teaches adamantly kind of work they're
trained in the society I thought I'll be
able to make a real difference I am a
maths and physics teacher are chica Rico
mixed secondary school the school is in
a very much area students most of them
they come from very poor families I
trained the religious life because I
wanted to be able to dedicate myself
wholeheartedly to helping others caring
for people is in my heart if I trained
this school I was teaching in a private
school which was were equipped had all
the facilities most of the students
there were that top three and then let
alone I felt that the surrounding
communities they also needed my help I
said let me stretch and extend the same
love to the surrounding community that's
what made me come to this school we are
going to start with maths
okay someone to remain as what we talked
about math students in the school faced
so many challenges they come from very
poor families even a 14 breakfast is
hard when they are in school they are
not able to concentrate mainly because
they are not able to get enough meals at
home
large area experiences come in every
three to four years food insecurity is a
major problem and teaching the members
within this community on new ways of
farming is a matter of life and death
was a populous occupied anaemia hapa we
are now heading into the dry season and
he trained out alternative ways of doing
vegetable that gather to take very
little water and it uses a very small
portion of land through peace Club the
students are united they conduct debates
the car out trip ranching and all of
that brings them together we need the
peace in our communities we need peace
in our art here in our school we have
already planted our to is flat one way
of promoting peace
[Applause]
by encouraging my student super-stretch
in science club and a current national
club they become very clean of fetching
the projects is about generating
electricity electric current flow plant
extracts and sewage wastes we entered
the fans week and we are called to
present there we became the Venus I've
been featured in the local newspaper I
feel recognized
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to be a great teacher you have to be
creative embrace technology you really
have to promote those modern ways of
teaching you have to do more and talk
less
[Music]